ma question s'adresse à la ministre des
solidarités de la santé nous ne pouvons
naturellement nous satisfaire de la
réponse qu'il y en est faite à notre
collègue lons le saunier fermeture de la
deuxième ligne du smur ploërmel
fermeture du smur cet été sisteron
fermeture des urgences de nuit depuis le
mois de juillet lens fermeture partielle
d urgence cet été toulouse fermeture
temporaire des urgences de nuit
mulhouse sud alsace fermeture temporaire
des urgences je pourrais encore
poursuivre car la liste est longue
notamment sartre comme cela a été
rappelé depuis le 24 septembre après
20h30 toute la nuit et pour plusieurs
semaines
le smur et le service des urgences du
pôle santé sarthe et loir sont fermés
cela met en péril la prise en charge
médicale du patient
25000 personnes se présentent chaque
année aux urgences de cet établissement
qui dessert un bassin de population de
150 mille habitants il manque neuf
médecins urgentistes
plus généralement c'est donc la double
peine pour les territoires ruraux leur
médecin généraliste qui partent en
retraite ne sont pas remplacés et les
services d'urgences de leurs hôpitaux
ferment dans de nombreux départements
lorsque les urgences sont pas fermées
par manque de médecins urgentistes
elles sont en grève la réponse
gouvernementale n'est pas à la hauteur
des attentes des professionnels de la
santé et des territoires
aujourd'hui les personnels sont au bord
de l'épuisement
que comptez-vous faire madame la
ministre pour juguler ce mouvement qui
s'amplifie
que comptez-vous faire face à la pénurie
de médecins urgentistes dans nos
hôpitaux